hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots if you make grinding and twerking
videos you could be monetized now gets
so hair spitting Les less speech more
sexiness on YouTube baby let's go what
about hot tub videos this content can
now earn ad Revenue oh good we will
still restrict monetization on Dance
videos with deliberate and recurring
shots on breast butt or genitalia so
basically every cool 9s rap video every
rap video ever yeah are you going to
take their are you going to take their
money away cuz I feel like you're not
going to take because I feel like to do
that you'd have to go through Vivo and
then you'd have to go through the labels
and then it would be a [__] mess in
court so I I get the impression that if
I were to you know watch uh last I
checked the Thong Song is still
monetized yeah I'm pretty sure uh two
shorts still making money off blow the
whistle okay that's a bang [__] out of
here I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
Luke is still getting his [__] Vivo
checks two live Cru to making their
money yeah okay yingang twins you got
that little John there go down the
[Laughter]
list John he was my favorite bro yeah
yeah smartest man in the world per word
he said he made the most money if you
break down every song how much money he
made if you just go by the words he said
he made the most money per word that's
not true cuz a lot of what juvenile said
wasn't even
words okay well we could say he made the
most money per mouth moov by the way
juvenile was named after his education
[Music]
level you got you got your titty in your
baby's mouth on YouTube
huh it's easier to rme when just rhyme
with the same word eh now you got it
monetized cuz you allowed to show the
nipple
Hound his Jewish producer changed his
name from sixth
grade oh [__] seual moves that mimic
sexual acts you making music videos with
sensual moves that mimic sex accent have
juvenile do this that would be so much
better hey Sage what if we get juvenile
to do it for rumble what if yeah that'd
be really good you want juvenile to do
this for the rumble creator Insider will
take care of it
yeah including you criticizing Israel
huh you feel the Palestinians got a
viable gripe
huh you think vaccines unsafe eh you
think the IDF shouldn't be shooting
children in hospitals
huh Can we remake that
song you a paper Chaser you control all
the
banks
Elon Musk is isra controlled opposition
ass the ADL came calling him and he bent
the knee H why did they leave those
bullets in the crib
ass as soon as green black got on the
phone he shut his [__] mouth
huh started tweeting about space Rockets
again huh CH was going to cancel all
their advertising ass Apple pulled 100
billion huh
turns out he found out who he can't
criticize huh the SEC is investig
investigating Tesla again based juvenile
rules oh [__] you getting called anti-pe
cuz you don't support the military
industrial
[Laughter]
complex they get mad at you when you
start
noticing
but then you can't stop noticing H oh
[__] oh [__] man Israel didn't even
exist before 1947
huh Google the kery plan huh oh [__] oh
[__] that was very
funny they bombed the US that's Liberty
you're not around to bring it up
huh oh God can we get me can we get
juvenile on this
show oh [__] their their motto is
through deceit Thou shalt make war
huh there's no such thing as a former
Massad Agent
H 2% of the population 50% of Congress
H they don't have to file his registered
agent
oh [__] man you did that paper chase the
Middle East on fire they want to
[Laughter]
hate they they bombing hospitals you
can't even send ow Troyer book
hat Alex rosen's only one only good ones
H 20 years for a peaceful
[Laughter]
protest hero cop getting stabbed in
prison
[Laughter]
ah oh [__] hey
man God damn bro oh we got a clip don't
ask me after this show what's the clip
it's this
clip oh okay we're done come on man
[__] you guys are so
stupid